After all, as Mizuhara said, there's
no way I'm in high spirits. [Music] Please wait. I can't do that.
What's the point of being patient? I'm in the
bad habit of leaving things to my emotions without telling them the requirements for winning. I'm
often told that I'm easy-going, but Paisen...  I didn't even
look at her with those eyes.I
had been curious about her for a long time, but when I
heard the sound of Paisen leaving, I couldn't
help but be drawn in.Even though I was curious, there was something about her.She
was a rental girlfriend, and she was a radish service
cross.
Even for a company, I was surprised that there was still a rental house left. I had
heard of her name, but I never expected that the person next door was like that.
Such a beautiful woman
turned out to be an adult girlfriend. I'm
sorry, I deleted everything. It's backed up to the cloud. Why is
this video even there?  What on earth did they shoot this year? What's more,
this kid is at the same university.
When I think of Suwon, I can't resist. I'm sorry, I'll
tell you everything, so please forgive me.
[Music] It's my
fault that this represents my child, and I don't blame anyone for this.
[Music]  ] In
this
situation,
that's how much I like that person. Or should I say I
like him?